other world news now and a drone strike
on an Open Air Market in Sudan has
killed at least 30 people activists and
medical workers posted video on social
media of what happened in a neighborhood
of cartoon last week Sudan's ruling
Council issued a decree to dissolve the
paramilitary rapid support forces more
than four months of fighting for control
of the capital has killed at least 4,000
people let's go live to Hiba Morgan our
correspondent in cartoom so Hiba what
more can you tell us about this strike
and who's responsible for
it well we know that it happened around
5:30 local time in the morning which is
around 3:30 GMT in the southern part of
the capital kartum and it's a place
that's densely populated by the
paramilitary rapid support forces and
that the Drone strike was carried out by
the Sudanese Army killing at least 30
people and it's not clear if all were
civilians or not but there is a dire
need for medical assistance for those
who've been injured uh as a result of
the Drone strike in the southern part of
the capital uh in that market now that
market is called the dougo market and
it's one of several markets that have
opened up since the start of the
conflict with many stolen goods so uh
many people say that uh it has become a
Target but it has that that has not been
clarified by the Army but there were
civilians there many civilians go there
uh to get some of their needs uh from
those markets those open air markets uh
and now 30 civilians or 30 people have
been killed including civilians and many
others injured but that was not the only
strike that has been carried out by the
Army on on on Sunday there were also air
strikes in other parts in the southern
part of the capital Kum around the
armored Core where the paramilitary
rapid support forces have been launching
attacks trying to capture a military
base and there were also artillery
strikes in the northern part of the
capital Kum so uh air strikes continue
artillery strike continues by the
paramilitary rapid support forces and
the Sudanese Army and civilians uh
continue to get caught up in the
conflict losing their lives uh when the
artillery or air strikes hit them yeah
and these strikes coming Hiba as the uh
head of the uh military Council Abdul
fatan Boran has been on a diplomatic
tour is there a sense that there is
progress on that front on the Diplomatic
front well we know that there are no
talks happening right now between the
paramilitary rapid support forces and
the Sudanese Army and the head of the
sovereignty Council and army Chief
General Abdul fatah Al borhan on
Saturday during one of his inspection
tours to military camps around the
country said that they welcome many
initiatives including the jeda Forum
where uh the United States and Saudi
Arabia are trying to mediate between the
two wearing sides but they say that they
do not accept uh uh unacceptable
interference and that was a response to
the African union meeting
representatives from the paramilitary
rapid support forces so the initiatives
are there there are some that the uh
Army is partic ating in but when it
comes to reality on the ground there is
no progress there is no uh ceasefire
that has been mediated over the past 2
months between the rsf and the Sudanese
Army to at least give a lull in the
fighting for civilians to be able to
leave a conflict zones or try to get
humanitarian assistance Hiba thank you
for that Hiba Morgan live there in
cartoon